things go totally off the rails in the
best possible way when a groove of life
on friends hit New Orleans and a girls
trip who come to stand up late
drinkin making memories that we can
laugh about for the rest of our lives
because that's what a girls trip is for
just go for
ah Jada pinkett-smith and Queen Latifah
have fun getting in all sorts of trouble
in New Orleans we're on set for the
stars first filmed together since 1996
is set it off yeah so nice being with
her on screen I realize that we waited
so long today is the last day that you
will ever be this young Regina Hall and
newcomer Tiffany Haddish add to the fun
on screen and off
Tiffany's the activities coordinator
justice will an eye on a swamp tour with
the group on what a group off with Will
Smith remind you that it was a coupon
dish you have for the room for us I
didn't understand yeah I got a real fun
but I have learned he has taught me so
much I'm teaching them how to save money
yeah I got it but what's in store when
this girl gang hits theaters July 21st
you don't see some fights some dance
baggage battles
you gonna see some small things but all
win have you know women did oh man the
movie looks like a lot of fun and I hear
there's a great cameo by some guy from
Entertainment Tonight
[Music]